four months after Hollywood suffered the
heartbreaking loss of both Debbie
Reynolds and her daughter Carrie Fisher
fans friends family and carries former
co-star r2d2 joined together to
celebrate the lives of the two iconic
stars at the Forest Lawn Cemetery in Los
Angeles California on Saturday this
entire thing I'm calling a show not a
memorial because my mother didn't like
memorials or funerals and she like shows
parties and she also loved her people
you are all for people she was always my
princess these are my girls this will be
it we're showing you this this is meant
for you and for the people Debbie the
Unsinkable and her beautiful daughter
would not ever want us to mourn oh yes
we can grieve a little at their loss of
the great joy of their presence but we
must also take great delight in the fact
that we had them for the time we had
them and that they filled their lives
with great accomplishments and brought
joy to people all across the world they
certainly filled our hearts you betrayed
me I myself feel personally responsible
in part for why Carrie at least is not
with us today because you see I once
saved her life
applying the Heimlich to dislodge a
Brussels sprout from her throat and if
I'd been with our beloved showboat I
might have been able to save her again
[Music]
how I love my pretty baby carried and
precious free baby I love my pretty baby
[Music]
time for the James Blunt song that he
wrote for Carrie
we met in a beautiful place you dance
are at all
[Music]
I go back there every single
I'm still shocked
[Music]